حسنًا ، أول شيء نحتاج إلى القيام به جون
هو التأكد تمامًا من وجود
تنسيق في جميع أنحاء العالم
في اختبار تتبع الحجر الصحي
وطرق التخفيف التي يتم
استخدامها في الوقت الحالي
كل تلك المكونات المنفصلة
الضرورية للغاية لإعادة العالم
إلى  يتم النظر إلى الأقدام بشكل مختلف في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، وحتى
يحدث هذا التنسيق ،
لن نحقق التقدم الذي
نحتاجه لتحريك العالم
مرة أخرى ،
فهل يستغرق ذلك من أربعة إلى ستة أشهر مثل
أوائل عام 2021 لتحقيق ذلك
على الإطلاق.  أعتقد أننا
في الواقع في وضع الآن حيث
يمكننا اعتماد بعض هذه الأساليب ، هناك
أنواع مختلفة
من المنهجيات السريعة والدقيقة القابلة للتطوير والتي يمكن
اختبارها الآن
والتي هي في المراحل النهائية
من التطوير وأعتقد أن الكثير
من البلدان  تجربة هؤلاء الآن
إذا كان بإمكاننا تبني واحد يمكن أن
يمنحك نتيجة إيجابية أو سلبية
لاختبار كوفيد
في غضون بضع دقائق حرفيًا
كل شيء
ولكن هذا ليس مجرد الصورة بأكملها
لأن المشكلة الأخرى بالطبع هي
فترات الحجر الصحي الممتدة التي يتم
تطبيقها في الوقت الحالي من وجهة نظري ، فهي في
الواقع تلحق بنا ضررًا أكثر من
أي من الإجراءات الفردية الأخرى
لأن الناس لا يفعلون ذلك.  لدينا الوقت
الكافي لقضاء ما يصل إلى 14 يومًا في
الحجر الصحي عند الوصول إلى وجهتهم ،
أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكانك تحقيق فوز مبكر
مع ربع جوي بين
دبي ولندن ، على سبيل المثال ، هناك
نقاش حول لندن إلى
نيويورك وإضافة بكين  أو شنغهاي عندما
يمكننا أن نرى
ممرًا جويًا قائمًا ليكون بمثابة
دراسة حالة
جيدًا ، نعتقد أن لدينا جميع الخطوات
المعمول بها هنا
وفي لندن لتحقيق ذلك ، ولكن
الشيء بالطبع
قبل أن نتمكن من توقيع أي اتفاقية
لدينا  للحصول على الحكومات على متن الطائرة
إذا كان بإمكاننا إنشاء ممر سفر
بين هنا ولندن ،
فيمكننا أن نرى سريعًا زيادة
هائلة
في ثقة المسافرين
ونجوم الأرقام  من أجل العودة ،
وهو ما سيكون مفيدًا للاقتصاد ،
يمكن أن نكون جيدين
اجتماعيًا وسنكون رسالة جيدة للمدن الأخرى
حول العالم لتحذو حذوها ،
لذلك نحن
حقًا حريصون على أن نكون من
أوائل المتبنين لهذا الأمر
الذي يركز عليه الجميع محليًا في الوقت
الحالي  بشأن الأولويات المحلية والحفاظ
على
سلامة سكانها ولا يفكرون في
تأثير الناتج المحلي
الإجمالي لقطاع السفر والسياحة.وظيفة واحدة من كل
عشر وظائف على المستوى الدولي واحدة من كل أربع
وظائف جديدة تم إنشاؤها أه قبل
الوباء
هو خطأ من جانب
الحكومات.  أعتقد أنه خطأ
لأنك بشكل فعال مجرد وضع
لصقة لاصقة أخرى ، فأنت لا
تتعامل بالفعل مع المشكلة ،
ما تحتاجه الحكومات لتحريك
رؤوسها هو حقيقة أننا لا
نتعامل فقط مع حالة طبية طارئة هنا
نحن أيضًا  التعامل مع
حالات الطوارئ الاقتصادية
والاجتماعية والسفر والسياحة هو أحد
مفاتيح استعادة ذلك